[Music]
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
what positions did you play
it looks like he spends a lot of time in
the gym please sit down sit down sit
down
it's good to be back
Governor hokel thank you for uh
welcoming us to your state as she's
helping New York lead the way of making
things in America and I mean making
things in America not importing them
making them sending products out
bringing jobs back and my friend the
majority leader Chuck Schumer can't be
here today I don't know what he's doing
he's just down there and trying to
settle a crisis of he's the best there
is man I want to thank him for working
so hard for the people of State
for being such a great partner
nobody's been a greater fight for
women's rights in the Congress and
Senator Christian gilliban God lover
[Applause]
I've been back and everything she's
going to do for a long time I tell you
what when she comes in it's asking for
something to see you just say yes
don't even start discussing it because
you're just going to give in anyway
she's taking on the military and she's
made she's a game changer and uh it's
great to see representative Jamal Bowman
lifelong educator
champion in Next Generation the
Republican Congress Michael Lawler is
here as well Mike's on the other team
but you know what
Mike is the kind of guy that when uh
when I was in the Congress they were the
kind of Republican I was used to dealing
with but uh he's not one of these Mega
Republicans which I'm going to talk a
little bit about I don't want to get him
in trouble by saying nice about them
or naked bottom but I thanks for coming
Mike thanks for being here this is the
way we used to do it all the time
and I want to acknowledge all the state
and local officials as well the
president of Belinda miles thanks for
hosting us and my
Madam president my wife teaches
full-time at a community college in
Northern Virginia and she's been
teaching for a long time
she says two things one
Community College is the best kept
secret in America
well they are and two equally as
important any education any any state
that out educates us any country that
educates is going to out-compete us it's
a simple proposition this is a really
important moment there's a big debate
going on in this country about
protecting America's hard-earned
reputation as the most trusted reliable
nation in the world about how how we fix
the long-term fiscal health of this
nation
the debate with enormous implications
for the American economy and quite
frankly for the world economy and that's
not hyperbole for the world economy it's
important for the American people to
know what's at stake this isn't just a
theoretical debate going on in
Washington the decisions we make are
going to have real impact on real
people's lives and that's what I'm here
to talk about today
so let me tell you a story about what's
going on
there's a very extreme Wing in the
Republican party and the House
Representatives referred to themselves
now I've been calling this for a while
but now they refer themselves as the
Maga Republicans
and they've taken control of the house
they've taken control they have a
speaker who has his job because he
yielded to the quote Maga element of the
party
they're doing the best to the best of my
knowledge what no other political party
has done on the nation's history they're
literally not frequently holding the
economy hostage by threatening to
default on our nation's debt that if
we've already that we've already
incurred we've already incurred over the
last couple hundred years unless we've
given to their threats and demands as of
what they think we should be doing with
regard to the budget
this would be incredibly damaging
here's what the speaker has put forward
for the Republican proposal he says he's
going to take the funding of how we fund
government back to what the levels were
in 2022 before the ominous bill
and they exclude any Cuts in defense he
said we're going to go back to spending
we spent in 2022.
but we're not going to make any Cuts in
defense which we spent in 2023 we're
calling for in 2023. you may remember in
the State of the Union I got our
Republican colleagues degree somewhat
spontaneously
uh
to protect Social Security Medicare from
any Cuts remember I said now let me get
this straight
you're not going to cut Medicare you're
not going to say that's right I said
well you know you're on you're on camera
they can see you
well so far they're not cutting Social
Security so far
and not only do they rule out any new
Revenue they're still determined to make
permanent the two trillion dollar tax
cuts was due to expire the Trump tax
cuts without paying a penny of it now
here look here's what that leaves us
with it's this basic sort of math
it leaves us with the requirement to cut
22 percent of everything else in the
budget in order to meet the requirements
they're demanding that we live at the
2022 budget numbers
the speaker and Republicans don't like
that I point that out
but that's not my opinion it's just
basic math
and here's what it does
it makes huge cuts and important
programs for millions of working and
middle class Americans
programs they count on according to
estimates the Republican bill would put
21 million people at risk of losing
Medicaid including 2.3 million people
here in New York state and 78 000 people
right here in Westchester County
devastated it's not right
Republican plan would cut federal law
enforcement officers thirty thousand
including 11 000 FBI agents two thousand
border agents DEA agents and so on
they're cut that's what in order to meet
the requirement they'd have to cut that
many
Law Enforcement Officers it risked
shutting down
375 Air Traffic Control Towers including
five right here in New York State like
Westchester County Airport because we
don't have enough personnel
and I've long believed that we have many
obligations as a nation but the only
I've heard me say this before I
apologize for repeating it but we only
have one truly sacred obligation we have
many obligations one sacred obligation
it has to equip those we send to war and
take care of them and their families
when they come home
for real
and that's why one of the reasons I
fought so hard and I was so proud to
sign the bipartisan pact act that takes
care of millions of veterans who are
exposed to toxic materials
that take care of their families as well
my son went to Iraq for a year
was one of the healthiest guys in his
outfit came back with stage four
glioblastoma have you lived just a
couple less than a quarter mile from one
of those major burn pits and you saw
what happened in the Trade towers that
went down what happened all those
firemen and exposure to toxic chemicals
but under the Republican bill today they
would cut 30 million veterans Health
Care visits the way they do that that's
including nearly 2 million Health Care
visits for veterans in New York state
because there's not enough personnel
Anonymous Personnel the difference
between the 2022 budget which they want
to get back to and the 2023 budget is I
increased the funding for the Veterans
Administration by 22 billion dollars and
the reason I did it
and the reason I did it and probably
some of you know of these folks
the number of you know more veterans
are committing suicide that are being
killed in battle
and so they pick up the phone they call
the VA in their area I need help
will come in in six weeks
come in and whatever
well we ended that we ended that now
they want to go back to the levels where
we cut those folks that now provide that
kind of help
this amounts to 22 billion dollar cut in
veterans Health Care
now they dispute this
they uh nowhere in their actual proposal
are their exclusive protection for
veterans but they say I'm it's unusual
language we use with presidents these
days they say I'm lying when I say that
well the truth is why do so many
veterans groups why have they spoken out
in opposition the Republican proposal
they're not all Democrats they know
what's going to happen
folks that's a game Republicans are
playing anytime you single out the
impact of their overall Cuts they tell
you no no it's not true
but they're wrong
they want to protect something they
would have written it down and say we're
protecting it you can't cut this program
you can't cut it
so you can see it here's another example
under the Republican plan
Nationwide one hundred thousand teachers
and support staff would lose their jobs
at the very time where attempting to
overcome the sufficient the incredible
deficiencies that occurred as a
consequence of what happened with the
pandemic
so many kids the average student out
there is about a year and a half behind
we don't need fewer teachers we need
more teachers
and by the way
no I'm
not being solicitous what we should be
doing and I'm proposing when I try to
finish this job
and proposing that we for example if we
start instead of Head Start which they
want to cut 21 000 Head Start spots in
this this state alone we should be
sending all the studies show that if we
send no matter what the background of a
child if we sent that child to a school
at age three learning Reading Writing
arithmetic through age three and four
and five we end up increasing by 56
percent the chance they'll graduate from
high school and go on Beyond High School
but look
we're here at a community college and by
the way this is one beautiful Community
College whatever no it really is
the property here is made
and the consequences here would be
severe here in New York it would cut the
maximum Pell grant that millions of
students use to get to Community College
by nearly a thousand dollars it will
eliminate Pell Grants entirely for 5 000
New York students
and here at another devastating
consequence they don't want you to know
about Moody's not a democratic outfit of
respected Wall Street analytical firms
said the Republican plan would cost the
country 780
000 jobs
yesterday I brought the Congressional
leaders together at the White House
to make sure America doesn't to fall on
its debt and for the first time in our
history and by the way I know the
speaker keeps saying 93 days ago I said
to Biden I want to talk to him and I
said fine I said you put down your
budget I'll put down mine I laid mine
down in detail on the four on the 9th of
uh of March he didn't put down his
so-called budget I don't know what what
you call it his connecting the two items
he didn't do that until five days after
he did it I invited him to the White
House
so folks look let's be clear
the debt we're talking about has
accumulated over 200 years
the last Administration alone the last
guy who served in this office for four
years increased the total national debt
by 40 percent in just four years
over the last decade the single largest
contribution of the Dead aside from the
pandemic was a trump tax cuts skewed to
the wealthy and large corporations
for two trillion dollars it made it
clear I made it clear America is not a
deadbeat Nation we pay our bills
and I was pleased
but not surprised by the Republican
leader in the United States Senate
McConnell who said after the meeting in
the white house and he went to the Press
he said the United States is not going
to default it never has and it never
will we shouldn't even be talking about
it and folks republicans in Congress
used to understand this in fact under
the previous president Republicans voted
to avoid default three times
this is not your father's Republican
party though
you know here's what's happened if
Maggie Republicans get their way
American defaults on our debt higher
interest rates for credit cards car
loans mortgages payments for social
security Medicare or troops veterans
could all be halted or delayed
according again to Moody's eight million
Americans would lose their jobs
including four hundred thousand New
Yorkers alone
our economy would fall into recession
and our International reputation would
be damaged in the extreme
we shouldn't even be having this such
we're talking about this situation as
you know I do an awful lot of foreign
policy with my my stent as a senator for
all those years and then as vice
president and I've traveled the world
I've met with over 80 heads of state 8
heads of state so far they all are
looking at me are you guys serious
no no I'm serious
because if we default on our debt the
whole world is in trouble
this is a manufactured crisis there's no
question about America's ability to pay
its bills America has the strongest
economy in the world and we should be
cutting spending and lowering the
deficit without a needless crisis
in a responsible way I Believe In
cutting spending and cutting the deficit
in my first two years in office I'm the
only president in history that's lowered
the deficit in those two years by a
record 1.7 trillion dollars
1.7 trillion dollars
and the budget I proposed back in March
would cut the deficit Again by nearly
three trillion dollars in the decade
ahead for example my budget cuts 30
billion dollars in wasteful spending on
tax subsidies to the gas and oil
companies they earned two what
tax subsidies aren't all bad but they
earn 200 billion dollars last year do
they need a 30 billion dollar subsidy
well look it cuts wasteful spending for
big Pharma we pay more for our
prescription drugs than any nation in
the world any advanced nation in the
world you can get the exact same drug if
you fly to Paris or London or to
Germany anywhere you've traveled Canada
and you that you and you pay here you
pay a lot more I'm big Pharma we cut
that spent by 200 billion dollars by
expanding the medicare's power to
negotiate prescription drug prices and
making drug companies
pay rebates when they raise prices
faster than inflation and we've already
cut by 160 billion dollars in savings
the bill we passed last year and it has
three parts to it by the way one didn't
one part didn't kick into January one we
said the price of insulin and Other
Drugs the price of insulin would be
reduced to 35 dollars
how many of you know someone with type
one or two but type one or type 2
diabetes
and you know
you know that's needed to keep they need
insulin to keep themselves alive or
their children alive or in good health
well guess what the price of insulin
went from four or five six hundred bucks
a month down to 35 dollars a month
for those on Medicare and here's the
deal it's not just it made it reasonable
for people to be able to stay healthy
but it saved the government a hundred
and sixty billion dollars because
they're paying less out
[Applause]
and by the way the other cuts that are
coming up because of what we did in many
with with regard to being able to
negotiate with Medicare it's estimated
we're going to save another 200 billion
dollars for example any of you know
someone who's on Medicare and also on a
cancer drug well guess what
they're paying right now sometimes 12 14
16 000 a year for the cancer drug
well beginning this next January the
most any seniors are going to have to
pay is thirty five hundred dollars for
all of their drugs and beginning in 2025
in 2025 they don't they've paid no more
than two thousand dollars for all their
drugs
by the way that saves the government
another 200 billion dollars because he's
not paying out for all the drugs come
forward and they come at a reasonable
price
my budget also Cuts tax loopholes look I
I don't have anything against Wall
Street or hedge fund's executive but
just pay your taxes man
no I'm serious
hedge fund's executive pay a lower tax
rate than the middle class worker who
works for them
no one earning less than four hundred
thousand dollars are going to see a
single penny and increase in their taxes
under me not a single penny they haven't
yet they won't
you're making if you're making more than
400 we'll start to pay your fair share
look instead we're making the biggest
corporation begin to pay their fair
share just did not
I'm not talking about 70 tax rates for
example at least pay something folks let
me ask you this does anyone think we
have a fair tax system in America
no I'm being deadly Earnest I'm not
going to be a wise guy
you got tired of hearing me say this I
pointed out there are 50 major
corporations in the 55 of the Fortune
500 companies that paid zero in federal
income tax after having made 40 billion
dollars in profits
40 billion so we instituted and got
passed the corporate minimum tax of 15
percent
well guess what
you all are paying more than that
just 15 percent
and it paid for everything we did
look I proposed a billionaire minimum
tax there are now one but went from
about 760 I think the number was to
around a thousand billionaires in
America well that's great if you want to
be a billionaire you can make it I'm I'm
not one of these guys to say you
shouldn't be able to do that and if you
want to be if you're a multi-millionaire
I'm not trying to say that can't happen
but at least pay something the average
tax paid by the Thousand billionaires in
America individually the average tax
paid is eight percent e-i-g-h-t 8
percent
no billionaire should be paying the
lower tax rate than a school teacher or
a firefighter
[Applause]
and another radical about this that's
why my budget also fully funds the
Internal Revenue Service you know and
it's kind of interesting Republicans
have been consistent for the last 10
years cutting the number of IRS agents
I wonder why
so we now have legislation in the past
that's going to that's in our budget
that says we're going to beef up the
number of IRS agents to thoroughly look
at the taxes of billionaires in America
according to the Congressional budget
office a bipartisan office they estimate
that just that alone would raise another
200 billion dollars a year Larry Summers
who's not what you call a wacko liberal
out there right
former president Harvard he says it's
more like
[Music]
my kids who went to Penn would disagree
but that's okay
but I went to a grade school I went to a
state school I went to University of
Delaware
but uh but all but but we're all kidding
aside estimates it would raise another
400 billion dollars a year a year
and they still wouldn't be paying very
much tax relative to their income to
begin with
my budget also has some of the strongest
anti-fraud proposals ever you may
remember when we had that the
legislation to help deal with the
pandemic what what Trump used to keep
doing is cutting the number of
inspectors General to be able to find
out whether or not this money's actually
not being wasted well guess what turns
out there was about there were several
billions of dollars that were being
wasted people were getting money they
didn't need or didn't deserve and this
and they were they were playing the
system
well you know I think that we should
have inspectors General again looking at
what in fact we're spending and whether
it's going where it's supposed to go
it calls for an unprecedented effort to
combat identity fraud for by tripling
anti-fraud strike forces to prosecute
pandemic fraudsters and seize back
stolen funds there's billions of dollars
in stolen funds that we haven't gotten
back yet
is transcendent inspector generals and
watchdogs for taxpayers dollars it's
estimated for every ten dollars every
one dollar we spend in firing these
folks it's going to save ten dollars ten
dollars
this debate is about fundamental choices
would you rather cut would you rather
continue a subsidy of 30 billion dollars
for big oil or cut 30 billion dollars
from veterans would you rather cut big
Pharma or cut health care for Americans
these are real world choices
that's what's at stake literally
you know I ran for president to see to
it that ordinary folks got an even Shake
I was raised in a family that was so
typical we weren't poor typical middle
class family my dad we lived in a
three-bedroom split level home and a
Housing Development that was a nice area
that was when they were developing
Suburbia with four kids and a Grandpop
living with us
I look back on I wonder how thin those
walls were for my mom and dad but anyway
but you know the truth of the matter is
that uh
um you know we my dad did fine I guess
by the time he retired he managed an
automobile dealership he was probably
making the equivalent of twenty thousand
dollars a year which would be like what
60 or 70 or 80 and I don't know what it
would be
but my point is that I thought I've
always thought the middle class folks
are getting the short end of things
I think the trickle-down economy not
much ever trickled down on my dad's
table that I can recall
and so when I ran and my whole career as
a senator was about making sure
middle-class folks get an even shot
that's why I believe we should grow the
economy from the middle out and the
bottom up not the top down but wealthy
will still do very well
because in the middle class does well
the poor have a ladder up and the
wealthy still do very well and that's
fine we all do well
we've made enormous progress just look
at what we've done so far over the past
two years we've created a record
12.7 million new jobs
more than ever in that period of time
including 800 000 manufacturing jobs
unemployment is at 3.4 percent the
lowest in 50 years
black unemployment is at one of its
lowest levels Hispanic unemployment
across the board in part our policies
are and the pace of our annual inflation
has been coming down for 10 months in a
row we still slowed by 45 percent we
still have more to do
but you know when we're in a position to
invest in America in all of America the
way we do that is we buy American
Products we hire American workers I get
to spend a lot of money the Congress
passes so if I have 60 billion dollars
of spend I and I'm going to have to put
new decks on aircraft carriers I don't
Outsource the work there was a law back
in the 30s that said buy American buy
American so we they have to use American
products they have to go out and make
sure that they hire American workers for
a long time and Democrat and Republic
administrations it was cheaper to go get
the cheap labor overseas and bring back
the expensive product no more not on my
watch not on my watch
instead of importing jobs abroad for
cheaper labor and important we're
exporting product and buying American
workers the opportunity to make a living
folks I signed the American Rescue plan
which sent 27 million dollars to this
Community College to keep students
enrolled
and to keep this school afloat help
vaccinate our nation got immediate
relief for folks who need it the most
and got our economy back in track
it didn't have a single solitary
Republican vote
then I signed the bipartisan
infrastructure law which had some
Republicans voting for it to build the
roads the best roads Bridges airports
Water Systems high-speed internet get
rid of all those those pipes that are
polluting in water Etc
you know how can we be the most
prosperous economy in the world
without having the greatest
infrastructure in the world we used to
be ranked number one in the world in
infrastructure you know we rank now 13
13.
next week this is an infrastructure week
remember all for four years in the last
guy we had infrastructure week every
week well under my predecessor of
infrastructure we became a punch line
on my watch we're making infrastructure
a decade a headline we're already
announced over 25
000 projects
and four thousand five hundred towns
across from across Westchester County
it's projects for better water
Wastewater and sewer systems repairing
dams and doing so much more I signed the
chips and science act which I felt very
strongly about
[Applause]
to bring back key parts of our supply
chain back to America remember when we
had real trouble on automobiles they
Detroit said they had to stop making
automobiles you know they take thirty
thousand chips I mean three thousand
chips well guess what they were all
being made in Asia and when the pandemic
hit they shut down so we were in trouble
folks these are the small computer chips
the size of the land of your little
finger nearly everything in our lives
from cell phones automobiles
refrigerators most sophisticated weapon
systems American vanities chips we
invented them we made them better but
over time we went from producing up to
40 percent of the world's chips to
producing only 10 percent despite
leading the world in research and Design
now we're turning that around the
private sector
I went around the world and at home and
I convinced people that they had to
invest in building the chip factories
here they call them Fabs Fabs factories
investing and guess what we've got a
commitment for Investments of
470 billion dollars in American by
American companies home and abroad for
manufacturing clean energy
like Micron and Syracuse investing 100
billion dollars over the next 20 years
to build semiconductors thanks to the
hard work of Chuck Schumer Governor
hokel IBM and Poughkeepsie investing 20
billion dollars over the next year
computer chipping
putting America back in the game and
creating thousands of good paying jobs
many of these jobs in the first of all
the construction takes a lot a lot of
jobs they don't require four-year
degrees when they're in these Fabs you
know what the average pay is going to be
close to a hundred thousand dollars you
don't need a college degree
that's progress
but I know folks are still struggling
with inflation
the way I think about it is the way my
dad used to talk about around the
kitchen table for real
he said how much are the monthly bills
at the end of the month you have enough
to pay for all your bills and just have
a little breathing room left just a
little breathing room
well that's why I wrote and signed the
inflation reduction Act
Americans pay more prescription drugs
than I said than any advanced country on
Earth
we're fighting for years to allow
Medicare to negotiate those lower drug
prices well we finally beat big Pharma
and we did it without a single
Republican vote
I'll have a we'll have a profound impact
and save lives it's already happening as
I mentioned earlier it's going to reduce
the deficit by 160 billion dollars just
this year
and how many of you know you know like I
said diabetes one in ten Americans have
diabetes Millions need insulin to stay
alive insulin has been around for 100
years cost 10 bucks to make it ten
dollars package it a total of twelve
dollars
and they're paying hundreds of dollars
making record profits well we kept it at
35 bucks as I said and we're going to
make sure we're going to make sure it's
capped at 35 for everyone not just those
on Social Security
because guess what it saves the taxpayer
money
the federal government doesn't have to
write a check for 400 bucks it weighs
the check for 35 bucks
look
inflation reduction act also makes the
biggest investment in fighting climate
change anywhere in the history of the
world
I was creating tens of thousands of jobs
as a giant step towards saving the
planet tax credit for consumers or
weatherize their homes many of you have
done it purchase the anti-efficient
Windows Doors appliances electric
vehicles can save an average of a
thousand bucks a year
look tax credits for States and
businesses employ renewable energy solar
wind hydrogen and more not a single
Republican voter for it this law and now
they want to get away with get rid of it
all
why would they want to repeal a law
that's creating American jobs and
lowering costs for American families
well when we have one we ever heard of a
republican opposing tax credits for
businesses
well that's what they're doing this time
take a look at the New York Times
yesterday what they wrote I think as a
front page
Texas now is becoming one of the leading
states in the nation in renewable energy
the number of wind farms they have solar
farms and hydrogen but now the
Republicans want to get rid of this law
and these tax credits well why do you
think that is
because the fossil fuel industry wants
to get rid of them that's why even
though they're creating jobs
taking on climate change
they don't want it because it's so so
much more costly to go the other route
they say cost too much but the truth is
it's too successful
and there's the real truth Big Oil
doesn't want it and Republicans are
carrying their water
that's what this is all about
let me close with this
we made so much progress but there's so
much more to do
we're on the cusp of a major change
we're creating jobs again American
manufacturers are booming again
where is it written America can't lead
the world to Manufacturing we're
lowering the deficit towns that had been
forgotten and left behind are coming
alive again
bringing back a sense of pride
all those chip factors a fact that I
talked about they're gonna be all over
America
they're not just going to be in the
Northeast and the West Coast they're all
through the central map you know people
who come from the people like for
example up in Scranton where I came from
where I was born and raised or other
states across the country
where all of a sudden the factories that
are employed
six seven hundred people for years shut
down and went abroad
not only did they lose the jobs they
lost their sense of pride
they lost their sense of belonging
how many folks do you have no folks in
the midwest who had their kids come up
and say Mom Dad I got a good education
but I gotta leave there's no jobs here
no reason to stay
we're bringing jobs back all across
America
this is no time to put all this at risk
to threaten a recession
to put at risk Millions adopt to
undermine America's standing in the
world Republican threats are dangerous
and they make no sense
folks we have to keep going and finish
the job I've long said it's never ever
ever been a good bet to bet against
America never
and I can honestly say
as I stand today I've never been more
optimistic about America's future than
them this very day because yesterday we
have to remember who in God's name we
are we're the United States of America
there is nothing nothing beyond our
capacity if we work together
God bless you all and may God protect
our troops thank you thank you thank you
thank you we got a fight we're going to
win this fight thank you
[Music]
thank you